parce que toi c'est vrai que tu fais moi
j'aime bien aussi parce que tu es un des
seul gars qui fait encore des coups de
gueule non c'est vrai là je t'ai vu la
dernière fois sur 7 à 8 euh tu avais
parlé des des réseaux sociaux les haters
sur les réseaux sociaux tu avais dit
c'est des scouilles qui qui parlent
derrière leur écran ouais ça sert à
faire briller les minables mais si tu
veux
[Rires]
euh c'est faile c'est facile d'c il faut
bien qu'il brille ces gens-là aussi
ouais à leur manière non bah c'est moi
mon album parle de tout ça ouais c'est
vrai ou jeis
voilà la la technologie le portable
j'avais lu une phrase pas mal
c'était à l'époque où les téléphones
étaient attachés on était plus libre
ouais mais c'est la réalité donc
aujourd'hui on fait avec tout ça je suis
pas dans un monde qui correspond à ça
dans ma tête moi moi je vis à la
campagne et j'observe des poules et je
peux te dire que depuis que j'observe
les poules je me dis mais avec
avec les coqus même et tout je me dis
mais c'est une une espèce de
société mais hyper intelligente quoi
hyper respectable onemmerdant de se
prendre plus con qu'une
poule et c'est ce que je compte le matin
est-ce que j'ai le temps il fait beau et
quand il fait beau on a le temps de
regarder les choses ici on est obligé le
scooter le machin il est mouillé bon
tous mou on est tous mouillés on est
tous mouillés dans quelque
chose tu as pas les réseaux sociaux toi
non non je ben non pourquoi tu veux que
je regarde des gens qui
m'insultent je saisme je ne sais même
pas ce qu'il pensent de moi mais quelque
part j'en ai rien à carrer en plus tu
vois ceux qui m'aiment bien m'aiment
bien ils ont raison je les aime bien les
autres j'en ai rien à taper non mais tu
as raison en fait c'est un peu ça c'est
une drôle deil philosophie quand même he
mais elle est hyper Simp toi mais je
suis sûr que sur les réseaux les gens
ils t'attaqueraient pas toi je sais pas
moi j'en sais rien mais si tu veux c'est
pas le propos le propos c'est d'éviter
de se faire du mal ouais non tu as rison
c'est donc voilà je vois beaucoup de
gens qui souffrent de regarder leur
réseau ou les les les les commentaires
des uns et des autres de gens que tu
connais pas toi tu es connu de plein de
gens que tu connais pas donc forcément
il y a des mecs qui vont te baver dessus
mais ils ont le droit moi il y a pas de
problème mais ça m'intéresse pas tuas
Ron voilà je je suis complètement
d'accord avec toi moi j'y vais j'y vais
très peu moi voilà juste pour voir les
gens qui insultent Gilber je rig je
rigole moi tu as des gros soucis
Gilbert je je dois s balle en plus j'en
parlerai dans un instant je dois 100
Ball à G jouré dans un instant Manu on
fera un on on va restens on faire un
quiz sur sur Gérard parce que je suis
très fan de Gérard je le connais par
cœur donc on va voir qui de toi ou moi
sais qu'on a tourné il a tourné beaucoup
de films ici ouais je sais il y en a
beaucoup tu as tourné quoi i une
histoire les bah les frères pétards tu
vois il y a une piscine ici on avait
fait tous les tous les décors des égouts
de Paris ici avec Villeray et c'était
pas rien Villeray dans les frères
pétards donc non on faisait tout avec
fchner ici c'était la maison on faisait
tous nos toutes nos répètes tous nos
films ici ouais euh Gérard aussi je
parlais de tes coups de gueule il y a un
instant il y a un truc qui t'énerve
c'est des gens qui prennent une pizza
avec de
l'ananas Layenne avec de la je sais pas
je me souviens pas j'étais en colère
alors tu es en colère ouais par s'il y
avait un mec qui a pris ça un jour bon
ça t'ava éneré de l'ananas écoute ça va
ça t'est passé oui on va dire que ça
m'est
passé tuacceptes si on mange ensemble je
peux tu seras pas énervé non mais ils
sont sur les réseaux ceuxl aussi ouais
je pense je pense qu' sont sur les
réseaux tu avais dit aussi la taxation
de l'état de l'État sur nos impôts tu as
déclaré les impôts je suis d'accord pour
les payer mais pas pour qu'on prenne
pour une
c'est pas mal je continue je
persiste hein là-dedans pas comme sur la
mais où va l'argent c'est ça que je
voudrais savoir si un jour on peut
savoir où va l'argent parce qu'on en
donne beaucoup ne le chauffe pas s'il te
plaît connais ça va faire
long ouis ben non c'est parce que
Monsieur Holland disait qu' 4000 € par
mois on était riche bon j'ai des
problèmes avec Hollande he j'avoue moi
aussi moi aussi donc il y a un moment je
pas développer tout ça c'est trop long
mais oui où va notre argent voilà c'est
ça qu'on voudrait ça
c'est pas que lui on voudrait savoir où
va notre argent cas il va pas dans les
fringes de
Daniel non mais je te le dis Non Non
mais quoi c'est c'est ouais ça ça TR en
fou ça mais laisse tomber vous avez
remarqué que rien de marche quoi ouais
c'est vrai rien de marche ah oui c'était
ça le quiz vraiment non non non t'inquiè
pas non non t pas t'inquiète doncquète
non non là revenais sur les rien de
marche tu veux parler de l'école les
hôpitaux la police tout ce qui devrait
marcher ne marche pas ouais ouais où va
notre argent mais je l'ai pas moi je
l'ai pas je l'ai pas moi il va où cet
argent on nous prend pour des cons mais
ça continue mais c'est pas grave il faut
le dire voilà c'est tout ça y est après
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien de le
dire ben ça détend c bien tu es mieux là
bah là je su
impeccable tu as déclaré aussi dans
Vivement Dimanche en 2013 j'emmerde de
journaliste ça va mieux
maintenant alors c'était par rapport à
un rôle que j'avais joué c'était celui
de mon mon Vidal ouis dans les Lyonnais
et il y avait un journaliste qui
travaille je connais son nom je sais où
il travaille et qui avait dit ben l'en V
c'est comme d'habitude il joue comme au
Théât enfin c'est n'importe quoi et moi
monont Vidal c'est mon ami et si j'avais
mal joué monont Vidal il me l'aurait dit
mon mais Monon il m'a embrassé il m'a
dit merci donc un compte journaliste qui
se permet après de faire réflexion parce
que c'est un frustré et qu'il aurait
aimé être acteur mais il n'est que le
journaliste sais que toi mais tu en fait
es mon votre
[Applaudissements]
double une belle
équip
vendcroyable en fait c'est c'est je vais
te lancer sur un autre truc on va penser
par sur tu as déclaré tu avais du
respect pour les for les forces de
l'ordre je comprends pas que les manif
antipol puisse exister si vous êtes
contre la police ne les appelez pas
quand vous avez un problème ne les
emmerdez pas bah voilà moi j'ai vu un
jour Mélenchon insulter un flic là euh
il sait pas à qui s'adresse oui bien sûr
il sait pas à qui il s'adresse ouais
pour parler aussi violemment à quelqu'un
qui euh a un boulot exigeant à faire des
couilles pour les faire et cetera la
police moi j'ai travaillé avec pas mal
de de gens de la DGSI autant que du raid
autant que et je les respecte je sais
qui ils sont et ce qui subit donc la
police est nécessaire on voit quand on a
un emmerde qui on appelle P pon la
police donc il y a un moment il faut les
respecter ou alors pas les
appeler chacun son
histoire dou non mais Gard sais qu'on
pense la même chose
surtout P surtout la même chose non mais
c'est un truc de fou écoute tant mieux
parce que des fois tu te sens un peu
seul tu vois on a l'impression qu'on
pense
un peu to much et parfois on rencontre
des gens à l'identique et ça fait du
bien parce que on est sincère dans ce
qu'on dit quoi c'est tout bête écoute là
tu es bien là tu es bien dans ton truc
là avec ton fils avec la tournée on a
l'impression que tu es un peu à part là
tu t'en
voilà
voilàan ve dans cet album j'ai pu dire
ce que je pensais avec mes mots à moi
sur beaucoup de choses et il commence à
être carrément dans l'actualité le truc
c'est ça et ça fait 2 ans qu'on l'a fait
mais il est encore plus dans l'actualité
qu'on l'espérait puisque l'actualité
devient ce qu'elle devient donc c'est
heureux parce que là les gens font la
différence entre un mec qui voulait
chanter pour se montrer et un mec qui
voulait chanter pour dire c'est ça toi
tu t'es dit je vais le dire je vais le
dire en chanson avec ma oui parce que
pour écrire un scénar il faut avoir une
certain certains talents de constructeur
je n'ai pas donc j'ai jamais pu écrire
un scénario donc je je je reste dans mon
rôle d'acteur et je joue les mots des
autres là je peux jouer les miens et
c'était important pour moi de de de
pouvoir les dire bravo en tout cas c'est
réussi et
vous l'Olympia le 6 novembre tourn dans
toute la France